to be the best you have to work the
hardest
it can't be perfect don't try to be
perfect it's impossible no one is
perfect
I believe I can't improve unless I want
to improve I want to be the greatest of
all time and that's just mom I said
nothing that I received individually is
impossible without those 14 guys because
of what they sacrifice each and every
day as I continue to grow I want the
guys around me to grow also
I'm LeBron James from Akron Ohio from
the inner city I'm not even supposed to
be here these kids have dreams I
remember me and my friends had dreams
every time when I'm not playing I'm if
the Lakers on TV I'm watching them I
guess so like you said it's me I got so
many different forms of leadership and
it just comes from a personality he's an
American professional basketball player
with the Cleveland Cavaliers he's won
two NBA championship awards and four
most valuable player awards he's the
Cavaliers all-time leading scorer he's
LeBron James and here is top 10 rules
for success basketball isn't easy
all my life I've been striving to make
myself better it's a full-time
commitment to be the best you have to
work the hardest you have to chase what
seems impossible over and over and over
again because giving up it's not an
option when you feel like you reached
your limit it's only the beginning
that's when it's time to dig deep to
find the courage to push some more
because if you got the drive the
discipline and the resolve to do what it
takes to make yourself great
in the rewards our illness
oh my
there was no way that LeBron was going
to be denied he was dispersed I can't be
perfect don't try to be perfect it's
impossible no one is perfect if you make
a mistake you have to live with it and
you have to be able to to grow from it
you can't continue to make mistake after
mistake at the mistake and then think
that you're going to be able to come
back from yes
you can see that one coming a mile away
barb David Jones don't you just let
McGinnis have the land one thing about
myself I'm real critical of myself I
believe I can't improve unless I want to
improve and ultimate I want to become
the greatest basketball player or the
best pair of LeBron James can be now if
that means I've become better than
Michael Jordan or better than Kobe
Bryant or Oscar Robinson then so be it
but if not I want to maximize my
potential so the times of my rookie year
where I was struggling I found a way to
get through it myself with the help of
friends and you know not having those
yes-man around me because I wasn't
playing well seven seconds left on a
24-second clock
LeBron against the long-armed Ariza in
trouble
but behind the backboard what a shot an
incredible shot by LeBron James I don't
know how we even solve a basket much
less put the ball in the basket for me I
understand that a lot gets thrown upon
my plate and a lot gets thrown upon what
I do
so for me my personal goals is to win
championships and at the end of my
career where I was able to accomplish
will make me happy and make me satisfy
because I don't play for I don't play
for what people expect for me to do
anymore
you know I want to be the greatest of
all time and that's just my mindset
wherever they lay me at the end of my
career and you know if it's not 1 9 or
12 or whatever the case might be Smitty
I had a great time I'm playing this game
that I love to put another scoring
option and a different way to score
coming off patient explain how he does
it again throws it right off of the
from the right corner he goes right over
Lucas it's like a stepladder honestly
you guys seen me sitting sitting in his
chair and kept looking over at them it's
because I'd rather be sitting over there
with them I know this is the individual
award but I would much rather be sitting
over there in shorts and a t-shirt
wondering what the hell they joking
about because I want to be a part of
that joke and I hate being out of all
the jokes I want to know what was
happening okay guys I would much rather
be with my guys over there because
that's what it's all about yeah much
rather be with those guys without those
guys this trophy is not possible the
Larry O'Brien trophy last year is not
possible nothing that I receive
individually is impossible without those
14 guys because of what they sacrifice
each and every day you know the sweat
and the blood and the time and
everything I always know that what
team's success becomes individual prizes
individual accolades but this really
doesn't mean much to me I'm humbled and
I'm happy about it but I wish it was 15
of these up here because I'm with a
great group of guys that allow me to be
the MVP each and every night
Kane's going faced ride of it
soaring about gets this crowd going my
goodness that's unbelievable our game is
more mental than it is your builders how
you apply that to the business world
because that's one thing that's really
big to you right now um just I just use
my instincts I use my instincts one
thing I did a few years ago I decided to
part ways with my agent because I
believed that I couldn't grow as a man
and as a business man having an agent
you know say well you know this is what
you need to do and this is how you need
to do it and I started my own company
with for my with three of my good
friends and it's called lrm our reach
our own marketing company I kind of
judge you know by my own standards did
did your friends that you hired have
experienced I mean not right so
seemingly not a wise business move but
there there would be a reason that you
would do that absolutely because as I
continue to grow I want the guys around
me to grow also you know so when LeBron
James is done playing basketball now
what do I have for my guys to fall back
on I don't want them to be like okay now
what do we do you know my guys are being
set up in a position now where when I'm
done playing basketball they can
continue to go on and be respected
walking into a business room be
respected on having their own business
ventures without but on me being there
and I can just sit back and collect the
check
News to play it in Bao James Laprade to
the hoop the Cavalier have won it you
get booked this one to the Cavaliers
LeBron James with big slide
for the cavalier we'll listen uh for me
I can't worry about what everybody say
about me
I'm LeBron James from Akron Ohio from
the inner city I'm not even supposed to
be here
that's enough every night I walk into
the the locker room I see at number six
with James on the back I'm blessed
so what everybody say about me off the
court don't matter
I ain't got no worse
and took me to the round
this is miss Gunther
situation LeBron James for those
brilliant parents let's please
understand and recognize that these kids
are future and without these kids
obviously we have no future so let's
continue to inspire I will I will do my
part I promise you that parents I will
be that second parent in your household
if you're a single parent mother or
father I will be that third parent of
your household if you happen to have a
mother and father at the same time but
you also have to do your part as well
these kids have dreams I remember me and
my friends had dreams I seen Brandon
twins here Frankie Walker she on cotton
Dru Joyce Willie McGee Romeo Travis and
the list goes on and on and on when we
grew up we had dreams and the reason our
dreams were able to become reality is
because we have mentors and family and
fathers and moms and people around us
that allowed our dreams to become
possible
again a smith screen Rosie will defend
well
do you gauge your game against Kobe is
that your Larry Bird no it is honestly I
look at Kobe Bryant as that guy that um
is the best one of the best in our
league every time when I'm not playing
I'm if the Lakers on TV I'm watching
them I'm watching him I'm trying to
learn from him and see how he may be
attacking a certain team that he's
playing because a lot of teams kind of
played me the same way they may play
Kobe with double and triple teams and
you know making you have to facilitate
to your teammates so I definitely look
at Kobe as that guy that you know he's
that guy he's that one goes behind the
back okay this time at 1:04 that's too
good right there this is unbeliev this
is your desk walking it down ROG
three change scars he has scored the
last 25 points for Cleveland this has to
be considered one of the great
postseason performances
it isn't everyone's not a leader and we
shouldn't expect everyone to be a leader
I think it becomes something that you
want to do or you're born with it and
some people lead by example some people
leave by a voice some people leave by
both and for me I felt in order for
myself to be as good as I wanted to be
and at the same time in order for our
team and be as good as I wanted it to be
I had to be both as well as we play last
game and ain't gonna be enough to win
tonight you got to get more dog you got
to protect one you got to help more you
got to sacrifice more in order to get
this win you have a lot of different
styles list let's throw some of them you
likewise teacher sometimes everybody
else I oh man um I got so like you said
it's me I got so many different forms of
leadership and it just comes from my
personality you know at times I can be
silly ladies beautiful got me looking
like iron man that times I could be
serious if you know Portugal you know
teammates you throw it up to the rim
that's like you throwing that st. pat's
check would you have to say you want
throw that passage at times I could be
like a teacher and be like you know
focusing in on all my students I'll come
right here so if I need to step once at
least I'm only stepping right at times I
can be the student you know and to be
able to have different forms of
leadership has helped me because you
have different personalities in the
locker everybody is not the same the way
I'll talk to be way may not be the way I
can talk to Chris on the way I'll talk
to Chris may not be the way I talk to to
UD or to burn or to real
everyone's personality is different so
my leadership skills has different
phases because I understand what I'm
doing five-four-three-two-one
sometimes you know the smiling
leadership sometimes to play for the
Brawn sometimes you use that as a formal
you should yeah absolutely I got that
from being around my childhood friends
we used to have so much fun and but we
understood when that ball was tipped
this is we're gonna have the most fun
here and I just brought that with me to
the NBA when you're doing something that
way and it's working in you're winning
and you're not disrespecting the game
right you did this is what you feel like
is how it's supposed to be done it's
giving me a sense of brotherhood in this
league that is hard to come by
Moe Williams will fill in the shard
Lewis play off the ball
Lewis gets it to LeBron for free
those kinds of shot
thank you so much for watching we made
this video for you Devon if there's a
famous entrepreneur we'd like to profile
next leave a comment below we'd also
love to know which of LeBron James top
10 rules meant the most to you leave in
the comments and we'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon
my expectation is always going to be
high because how fill out the individual
I feel like I continue to get better
every year
I continue to bust my button off season
to get ready for a season that going to
June so I look forward us competing for
NBA championship this year and every
night I go on the court I approach it
that way on that's trying to to get
better for the long term goal short term
goal we want to just continue to get
better every night so how do you stay
motivated and you do both off the court
and on the court um I'm in a position
where I can be the best I can be
each and every night I have a
organization I have a team
I have great coaches around me that that
can put ourselves in a position to be
the best each and every year and then
personally I hold myself up to a
standard higher than anyone so that
keeps me going as well certainly
athletes are trained to say I just want
to play and I want to win and this is
the most important thing to me and then
when you make a decision and we saw it
in the movie that this isn't the most
important this is what I do but it isn't
the most important thing to you is that
a trend play the guys in your dressing
room who don't share the same value as
you well that's why you have guys in our
league that's superstars and you have
guys the stars and then you have all
stars and you have guidance ok players I
mean I accept the challenge every night
every night I go on the basketball court
in everyday life I accept the challenge
because I realize I'm not just
representing LeBron James I represented
you know my two sons I represent my
family
I represent everybody in my household
and also the city of Cleveland and now I
have an even brighter mind now I
represent the United States of America